the prime minister's in a lot of trouble
isn't he
well look actually i think this will be
an opportunity today to
uh have this vote uh i hope that mps
will overwhelmingly support him i think
uh i believe that they will um that will
uh i hope as well but draw a line behind
uh some of this has been speculation for
weeks now
and then we can move on and i think the
the choice is going to be very clear
we've got a prime minister's got the big
calls right on the vaccine rollout on
the getting the economy fired up the
leadership he's shown on ukraine we've
got a whole packed agenda we've got a
general election in less than two years
packed agenda on leveling up on skills
of course the cost of living
the
crime and law enforcement which is one
of my areas working with pretty patel or
we can turn inwards with what i think
the public will view as a rather
self-indulgent bout of talking to
ourselves and so i think it's important
people get behind the prime minister and
i'm confident they will
why do you why do you think they will
why are you confident that they will
well i think the conversations that i've
had overwhelmingly uh people want to see
us put the
the the partygate issues behind us
clearly mistakes were made i think the
prime minister's address that uh he's
overhauled number ten he's shown the
contrition made the apology but also
we've got this packed agenda which is
where people really want our focus to be
and i think that
the idea that we go into what will be
months not days not weeks but months of
what will be viewed by the public as a a
conversation amongst ourselves with all
the things going on both the cost of
living here at home
but also internationally things like
ukraine i i think that will feel to to
many people uh as self-indulgent uh at
this uh important crossroads so i hope
people get behind the prime minister and
i as i say i'm confident they will and
that's based on the conversations that
i've had although we know that at least
54 people at least 54 have decided that
he is not the right person for the job
how many
votes would he have to win by in order
for him to continue to enjoy your
support or looking at it another way how
many might the rebels have to get in
order for you to think twice
i'm not going to start speculating on
the numbers game i know you have plenty
of people that will come and do so i
would just uh encourage as many people
as possible and be speaking to
mps today to encourage them to support
the prime minister because it is either
getting on with the job on the cost of
living
on the nhs recovery from the pandemic
our reforms from social care to the bill
of rights
and and that packed agenda with with
less than two years to an election or a
conversation amongst ourselves for weeks
and months uh with i i do not believe
anyone who has got a plan or who's uh uh
articulated uh what will uh what will
otherwise be viewed as a rather
self-indulgent internal conversation
amongst the party itself
jacob rees-mogg says he only needs one
vote he only needs to win by one vote
he will continue to be prime minister
and he will continue to enjoy jacob
rees-mogg's 100 support would you say
the same thing
yes i'm fully supportive of the prime
minister and i'm confident he'll win
tonight
even if he only wins by one vote you
still think he's the right person for
the job
look i i think he's the right person for
the job as i said i'm not going to
speculate on numbers i'm confident he'll
win by a lot more than one
you think you'll win the two by
elections coming up
well by elections are always difficult
they're the the there's always the uh
local as well as the specific
circumstances that give rise to them
what i'd say is we've got a big majority
a big working majority we've got a
packed agenda uh we often see a midterm
blues at this point in the electoral
cycle but the key thing is actually um
the the difference in the polls is not
uh particularly great by uh or
particularly significant by historical
standards where you think where labour
would need to be including if you look
at the local elections which is also
pointed out as a barometer and we've got
this very important agenda and we've
come through a very difficult time uh
for the country above all but also in
british politics uh with the pandemic i
think the war in ukraine is testing us
in all sorts of ways both as a country i
think the prime minister has shown the
leadership on that but of course it's
had an impact on the cost of living and
energy bills um and what we really want
to do is be focused with a laser-like
precision on those bread and butter
issues that the people of this country
care about and of course uh a a
leadership process uh once that's
underway i i believe will distract from
all of those important things that
whether you're in the suburbs or in the
cities or in the rural areas of the of
our great country i i think it will feel
like a distraction and i think it will
feel like a very self-indulgent one so
what i'm saying is people should come
together we've got a pact agenda it's
incredibly positive we're the only ones
with a plan to tackle these issues and i
think we need to get on with that job
and yet and yet uh people who are
royalists gather at saint paul's
cathedral on friday and boo this prime
minister and his wife as they're walking
up the steps to mark the 70th
anniversary
of her majesty uh on the throne um
is this party tone deaf are you not
listening to that
well in fairness people were cheering as
well as booing they were
absolutely that's part and parcel of
politics and politics has become more uh
factionalized and polarized these days
but of course we listen but what what
ultimately people care about um is not
whether you've got a few hecklers at
some public event but whether you're
focused on their priorities and the
great silent majority of this country i
think expect our attention to be on
those issues and that's again why uh
getting on with the job at hand the
packed agenda the positive agenda we've
got building off the queen's speech and
the legislative gender as well as the
practical issues around the cost of
living with the 15 billion pound package
of support i think is so important and
anything that distracts from that i
think uh does lead to more consternation
and more apathy amongst our electorate
well if not the hecklers as you describe
them at semples what about the
anti-corruption czar who's resigned this
morning saying he can no longer
work with the prime minister
well look uh i i know uh john penrose is
uh um you know i've known him uh since
i've joined the house of commons and mp
and there'll be of course we've got a
leadership uh vote later on so you'll
you'll have the chance to hear from all
the centers all i would say is that the
overwhelming majority of people that i
talk to mps want us to put these
distractions uh
behind us
are not minimizing the party gate issues
they're significant but the the
investigation has concluded the su grey
report has been published the prime
minister has acted um and what what i
think
the mps i talked to overwhelmingly say
to me is that they want us to get on
with the job and talk about the issues
that their constituents care care about
and the biggest distraction of that
would be
a leadership
contest which would last for not days
not weeks but months um and we know that
the public are particularly unattracted
to divided parties i think it's the time
to get behind the prime minister and get
on with the job well if not the
partygate what then about jesse norman
who was a former treasury minister i
believe um stepped down in september of
last year his cause called some of the
actions of the prime minister this
morning in his resignation letter or his
suggestion that he wants the prime
minister to resign as grotesque
you'll hear from all the dissenters
that's why we're having this vote um but
of course they're the the quiet silent
uh majority will actually get to have
their say and the question and the
choice will be do they agree and i
respect uh jesse and john but i disagree
with them fundamentally i think this
prime minister's got the big calls right
on the vaccine roll out getting the
economy fired up fastest growing economy
in the g7 last year second fastest
predicted this year we've got then of
course a series of challenges on the
cost of living but we're the ones with
the plan on energy bills we're cutting
national insurance in july uh we've got
the energy rebate uh 400 pounds of cash
grant in october we're the ones with the
plan getting on with that job i think
anything that just
detracts or distracts from that uh is uh
is something that the public will regard
as unappealing and uh
and and uh ultimately self-indulgent so
i think it's a time for unity for moving
forward
could you not do that with a different
prime minister
well it will take weeks it will take
months uh i i don't think the party um
has a settled view um and uh
there will always be people that will
disagree with whoever the leader is
that's natural because you have a vote
and we decide things in a democratic way
um
and i think the net up shot will be more
disunity and more distraction and more
internal conversations within the
conservative party around the outward
facing focus on the public's priorities
and i think that's what people want most
of all right now and that's certainly
what i think
our constituents and the public want
we heard from sir graham brady saying
proxy votes will be made available to
those mps who cannot find themselves in
the chamber
or in the house of commons today will
that uh also include the um unnamed
conservative mp who's accused of rape
i don't know uh that will be for the
1922
uh committee to decide that and i'm
afraid i just don't know the answer to
that question
well you're a lawyer and of course a new
and justice secretary as well do you
think that it should include that mp
i look we we've answered all of these
questions in relation to the whip and
the process that's going to be followed
uh there's obviously not been a charge
yet i don't want to say anything which
prejudice is that
of course it's not going to prejudice
that at all is it deputy prime minister
i'm just asking you as a as a senior
politician also as a lawyer also as the
justice secretary do you think somebody
who has been
accused of rape and is no longer allowed
in the chamber at least for now should
be allowed to vote tonight
i'm not going to say anything which
comments uh on the matter which is
subject to uh that the police
investigation described i think that's
the right thing for me as the justice
secretary to to do
why why would it impact on that
i think any commentary particularly from
someone who holds the office that i do
uh could be regarded as either
interfering one way or another and uh i
will want to avoid that scrupulously
even if they are anonymous we don't know
who they are
yes